have breaking news right now out of the
u.s supreme court
the supreme court has rejected the
texas-led effort to toss out
election results in four key states
that joe biden won again that is a
rejection to take up this case the
supreme court
just issuing that statement this was as
president trump called it the big one
the case that was going to wrap
in everything trump supporters holding
out hope that this
could be the case that the supreme court
court would take on its merits and
actually argue before the court
that is not happening fox news chief
legal correspondent anchor of fox news
at night shannon breme tells us
what is the decision by the justices
good evening shannon
good evening brad we just have a couple
of paragraphs and this is how they spell
it out they say the state of texas's
motion for leave to file a bill of
complaint
this state by state uh controversy they
wanted to bring to the court directly it
says
it's denied for lack of standing texas
has not demonstrated a judicially
cognizable interest in the manner in
which another state conducts its
election saying you know texas was
claiming here the way that these four
other states conducted their elections
and changed things at the last minute
they
they texas accused these states of
exploiting the pandemic
to change things like witness
verification signatures voter id those
kinds of things
the court here basically is saying um
they don't have a cognizable interest a
legal
challenge that we can weigh in on here
now there's a statement by justice alito
justice thomas joins him in this and
says in my view we do not have the
discretion to deny the filing of a bill
of complaint
in a case that falls within our original
jurisdiction so
very few of those cases they go straight
to the supreme court but state versus
state is one of those things that
happens there
they say they'd grant the motion to file
the bill of complaint but wouldn't grant
other relief and don't express
their views on other issues essentially
what it means here for texas is that
they don't get to move forward this case
is done you don't have enough you would
have needed five justices to move this
thing forward
so texas's last ditch effort to go after
those four states and nullify which
essentially would have been i think
about 39 million votes of other people
in those four other states it's not
going to happen the states at all said
texas has no
right to do it and for now the supreme
court says this is the end
that case is going nowhere we're not
going to get involved and texas
essentially does not have uh what they
need here which is a cognizable interest
and they have a lack of standing so the
case is done
this is it yeah that was
the big one let's bring in jonathan
turley professor at george washington
university law school
shannon stand by if you would jonathan
we talked
earlier this week about the pennsylvania
case that the supreme court did not take
up and decided to not move forward with
to hear
essentially hear that case forecasting
perhaps that they really were not
in this on on these cases however this
this
how it's written does not foreclose any
other pending or future
election case coming before them there
are a few more irons in the fire
but the electors vote on the 14th
right and so we're right on the eve of
that vote
uh this is very similar to what happened
in the pennsylvania case
uh the white house was only able and
texas was only able to secure
two justices and that was primarily on
technical grounds that they had to
really hear this case uh not because of
the merits but because of how it came
before the court
obviously the other justices seven of
them disagreed even on that point
and so this is as dead as dillinger and
the question is
uh can these other remaining cases still
have a chance
to make a difference tonight we also had
word out of the wisconsin supreme court
that they will review a challenge in
that state
uh but that is just one state and we are
now
not only running out of runway we're
running out of time
yeah shannon bring you back into this
conversation as well running out of time
but also as jonathan points out you need
to have multiple states for the
president to
essentially take those electoral votes
away from joe biden
and they are going to vote on monday
they're supposed to
and that was the whole goal with texas
going after big ones that would have
really helped the president
georgia michigan pennsylvania and
wisconsin so it was very targeted it was
very smart to go after those states
which all of those electoral votes had
they flipped to
president trump obviously would have
changed everything so
now we do have these state level
challenges there's one in georgia that
was filed in state court that
folks think has some life to it but
again that takes a lot of time to
proceed through the state court system
wisconsin's supreme court has announced
that they're going to hear
they're they're skipping the appellate
level there in wisconsin they will
actually he'll
hear oral arguments tomorrow noon local
time there in milwaukee
to move forward with a case in wisconsin
so those are two critical key states
but as for texas trying to go after four
states at once
that math is not going to happen because
this case as professor turlia said it's
this is the dead end for it so now we're
left with these collection of state
cases
uh they're also running out of time and
out of um
you know landing space as professor
turlia said but they are still active
yeah let's bring in kristen fischer at
the white house uh kristen the president
had put a lot of eggs
in this texas basket he talked about it
a number of times including
at a christmas party at the white house
saying this was the big one
your thoughts about what's going to be
the reaction of the white house he's
tried the state legislatures it has not
worked
these cases seem to have stopped there's
a few more as we mentioned
but this was the one that he talked
about a lot
yeah as you just said he i mean this is
the one that he called the big one
brett i'm really watching the
president's twitter feed right now
because he has tweeted at least twice
today
about this case really putting a lot of
pressure
on the supreme court and perhaps
particularly those three supreme court
justices
that he appointed to the high court he
said
he tweeted to them today you know to do
the right thing
to have courage have wisdom he even told
them to
save the united states of america so
president trump has really made it no
secret that
he thought the supreme court should take
up this case
but now this is definitely another legal
blow for
the president his legal his uh his legal
team his campaign
and his efforts to overturn the outcome
of this election and now you have
the electoral college meeting on monday
but you know brett it really remains to
be seen
how much further president trump intends
to go because
as of today he has tweeted multiple
times about this so we will see but as
of now no response officially from
the white house the president or his
legal team
just yet but we're watching it brett
yeah and obviously the politics of all
this as the georgia runoffs there's
still the senate
control hanging in the balance on
january 5th and how that plays
all of this in that is very important
last word jonathan turley
on this it seemed like these legal
challenges some of them
um constructed in a way that the judges
some of the judges at least
when they looked at them said i need
more
meat on the bone as far as evidence that
that the votes were
stolen or fraudulent that's right this
wisconsin
appeal to the supreme court which is
skipping an appellate stage
does look at these concrete allegations
there's about
221 000 ballots that are being
challenged in two
largely democratic counties but with
this decision
it's hard to see even if that was
successful that it would make any
difference obviously
with the balloting coming part of the
problem i think that we're seeing is
that many of these cases are being
thrown out on standing
or procedural grounds and there are a
lot of voters out there who believe
that this election was not fairly done
and they don't feel like the evidence
has been scrutinized so i think the
supreme court decision is going to
fuel that objection because this was
made as a threshold procedural issue
texas simply cannot sue to get other
states
to change their view of their own laws
or practices
but jonathan the fact that they're not
even moving forward to hear it suggests
that
does it not that the supreme court is
kind of laying down a marker
that you have to get over this certain
point in order
not just on standing for texas but on
the pennsylvania case as well
that's right i mean these were not close
calls for the supreme court
the pennsylvania case didn't didn't have
a single dissenting justice
and was dismissed 40 minutes after that
last brief was filed
so these are really troubling
developments for the trump legal team
they've never
found tierra firma in any of these cases
they've never been able to really
move this this litigation forward
but this is a huge blow because the
president obviously has been talking
about it
there are six conservatives on the
supreme court three trump appointees
and they're not they don't have animus
towards the president the majority
obviously does not have that animus
they're republican appointees
three of them were appointed by him they
just don't see the law here they don't
see the credible legal argument
and that's why this came out the way it
did